cuando robaste el auto no revelado
reunimos a siete personas que cometieron
un delito cometí un delito cometí un
delito
cometí un delito cometido un delito
cometí un delito cometió un delito
cometí un delito uno es un policía
encubierto si el grupo descubre quién es
el mentiroso podrán repartirse el premio
si el mentiroso sobrevive el se llevará
todo el premio quién es el impostor
cuál es el nombre de todos y por qué
están hoy aquí mi nombre es trina y
estoy aquí porque yo tengo multas por
conducir ebria y multas de tránsito soy
jeremías y mis condenas son recepción de
bienes robados posesión de parafernalia
y embriaguez en público y perturbación
de la paz soy andrew cuando tenía 15
hace cuatro años
me arrestaron por hacer grafitis en una
pared soy aquí siendo menor de edad
estuve en un asalto a una tienda con un
grupo de amigos y me arrestaron yo soy
rico
carreras conducción temeraria y evasión
hola yo soy kenia y mi última condena
fue por intento de fraude soy soy yo
también me metí en problemas con la ley
por carreras callejeras al principio era
impreciso como sus gestos parecía un
poco nervioso a qué se dedica cada uno
está pisó autos hago tapicería civil y
lo seguro lo siento tu eres aquí y si tú
qué haces tengo curiosidad escribo
libros escribes libros que claro te
quitarás la guardia del summa por favor
si solo intento mirar porque muchos
policías tienen
de acuerdo y cuando conseguiste tu gta o
lo que sea gta gta en realidad fue este
año no dijiste que era gta o carreras
carreras callejeras y voto del público
quien es el topo
note que trina está acusando a todos los
demás
[Música]
solo la forma en que estaba de pie muy
recta sabes los policías son muy grandes
[Música]
creo que porque siendo yo el único
afroamericano sería como tal vez es el
elegido es la distracción y vamos a
decir a qué se dedica cada uno como
profesión trabajo en el centro de
ciencias de california llevo allí dos
meses soy terapeuta soy barista tengo
curiosidad cuando robaste el auto no
robe el auto
del lugar
descuida pero estaba haciendo algunas
carreras callejeras los policías son
conservadores y son corredores
callejeros como es que no tienen ningún
tatuaje yo sí los míos están
relacionados con el anime tengo a chen
long aquí el anime se comprueba sé que
hay de ti no tengo tatuajes por motivos
religiosos y soy no tenía ningún tatuaje
no parecía tener un historial criminal
que pareciera realmente legítimo esos
son pendientes reales o los que tienen
imán son imanes hermanos y
tengo mis sospechas porque alguien
llevaría pendientes falsos bueno estirar
las orejas duele y después huelen y yo
soy muy sensible al olor me dan arcadas
alguien estuvo en la cárcel y estuve
tres meses tres meses debía cumplir dos
años pero tenía un hijo muy pequeño y el
juez se sintió mal por mi salud en ese
momento entonces se adelantó y tuve que
cumplir ese fin de semana y me liberaron
igual hace como dos días fui al tribunal
que tal tú no nunca tuve que ir a la
cárcel particularmente no estuve en la
cárcel porque el policía que me detuvo
literalmente es un habitual de mi
trabajo y este hombre sólo dijo hermano
y yo estaba como lo siento mucho amigo
se confiscaron el auto así que ni
siquiera te dio una condena y si lo hizo
y dijo lo mismo aunque no me llevó a
cumplirla así que así que silencio
[Música]
desconfiaba mucho de isai porque eran
demasiado bonachón
tenemos un triple empate
el empate es entre y saint andrew y
kenia me mire en el espejo cuando llegué
aquí dije este no es el traje adecuado
para lo que trato de representar cada
uno entenderá 20 segundos para exponer
su caso febrero estaba corriendo me
pararon marzo tuve un juicio tres meses
licencia suspendida se incluyó en mi
historial pero eso es lo único que he
hecho por eso el policía no se llevó mi
auto he conducido durante siete años sin
ninguna multa a mis antecedentes penales
son bastante extensos pero empecemos por
mi último y definitivo arresto me
arrestaron en el banco y estaba cobrando
un cheque todo salió mal y cumplir tres
años y medio no fue mi primera condena
tenía muchos antecedentes cuando tenía
15 años y era un grafitero así que
cuando en mi primer año hice un graffiti
la policía me atrapó cerca del colegio
por suerte no fui a la cárcel porque era
la primera vez que me detenían como
menor entonces lo que hicieron fue
ponerme una multa
ah
y sae
seguro buena suerte no tengo tatuajes ni
piercings así que supongo que eso no los
convence por favor levanten la mano si
todavía tienen dudas y quieren continuar
con el juego
estaban en el bloque de corte así que
tengo curiosidad porque creen que
pensaríamos que serían ustedes dos me
veo demasiado correcta no me he visto
así nunca porque soy una ama de casa
normalmente me encontrarás en sudadera
creo que también voy vestido un poco
formal tengo los brox creo que es la
pieza en máscara que llevo lo siento
volveré a los pendientes si no eres
policía porque no puedes conseguir los
pendientes de verdad lo intente y
estirar las orejas duele pero no en ese
calibre no lo hace no me pareció
demasiado sospechoso pensé que tal vez
solo le gustaba el aspecto a qué tipo de
drogas han consumido en el pasado quizás
todavía las consuman y yo iré primero de
xm yerba alcohol básicamente he probado
casi todo no me gusta la yerba me da
jaqueca el alcohol sí así que en el
instituto
empecé a beber alcohol me convertí en
alcohólico con mis amigos luego superé
me dicción pero de vez en cuando cuando
estoy con mi familia puedo tomar una
copa ocasional él dijo que era
alcohólico a una edad temprana me
pareció un poco raro diría que incluso
por carreras callejeras podría ver a las
personas contratando t por qué no se
puede decir que es como un crimen creo
que no hay nadie que salga herido el mío
estaba en autopista 210 pasando por
pasadena iba a 177 kilómetros por hora
no vi al policía estaba aparcado en el
lateral que atraparon por exceso de
velocidad pero había otro era 4 si
cuando para se tardaron en alcanzarme
porque partía de la nada así que dijeron
que estaba evadiendo así que eso fue
algo adicional y fueron dos mil dólares
en multas me confiscaron el auto durante
30 días me suspendieron la licencia
durante un año sin embargo creo que el
historial podría seguir siendo bueno
para los policías no quizás tienes razón
parecía un poco más tranquilo
[Música]
o sea todos a dios
demonios
estoy un poco desanimado porque mi madre
me apoyaba además le dije soy un ganador
para ti y todo eso pero quiero decir
está bien por favor levanten la mano si
quieren continuar el juego en 3 2 1
qué opinan de la policía así que iba a
decir que eres el psv de psv saben lo
que significa que significa todos los
policías son bruta sensual bastardos y
trina y jeremías se asociaron ella se
equivocó así que tan pronto como vi que
se equivocó traté de acercarme y ser
parte de su grupo me da ansiedad
simplemente ir en el auto cuando un
policía se puede ver de verdad empieza a
ayudar me asusto empiezo a buscar mi
cigarrillo no de verdad es una locura es
malo me siento incómoda con ella sé que
hay buenos policías por ahí pero creo
que solo vemos lo que quiero decir si
vamos a ser realistas
pero creo que vemos tantos en los medios
de comunicación mier y demás que sólo
abusan de su poder ni siquiera me siento
cómoda con los militares soy un hijo de
militares de tain siento que son
diferentes a los policías muchos de
ellos vienen de la guerra y luego se
convierten en policías y ahí no estoy
segura de dónde están ahora porque donde
estoy no no no no ellos en general tengo
una pregunta de cómo se siente en tus
padres al respecto considerando que eres
un mocoso militar creciendo una familia
así así que esperaban que nos
descargaremos de ese tipo de personas
cuando vino contra mí me pareció raro
porque quería desviar la atención de
ella
creo que el topo sigue aquí me siento me
estoy sintiendo un poco incómoda aquí
siempre me han gustado los ahora sí que
sí pero sí que las carreras callejeras
eran lo que esperabas un poco
podría haber sido el
policía ya que era un mocoso militar
[Música]
lo sabías usted es mucho demasiado usted
es mucho con buena suerte por favor
levanten la mano si todavía quieren
seguir jugando en 3 2 1
entonces por qué no levantaste la mano
cuando dijo que siguiera jugando crees
que ya sabes o si siento que son
demasiado evidentes para ti sentí que
los tatuajes se descartan
automáticamente porque siento que no los
podrías tener tan visible creo que lo
que me alarma de ti son los falsos y la
razón si alguien los quisiera y el
estilo sería real no porque entonces no
tienes que tener siempre el imán estás
en el campo de la medicina yo dije que
soy terapeuta se considera eso dentro
del campo de la medicina la psicología
trata del cerebro y entonces porque sé
que se necesita una
especie de registro limpio quiero decir
realmente no puedo pensar una vez que
eso al menos mi junta de ciencias del
comportamiento es muy indulgente con eso
solo estoy pensando en por qué las
enfermeras no pueden ejercer su
profesión si tienen todas las enfermeras
administran medicamentos es peligroso
pueden estar robando la medicina pueden
sacar no puedes hacer eso soy terapeuta
no siquiera vienen y ahí es donde estaba
la confusión tratando de despistar
[Música]
muy bien bien creo que él era yo también
sí me sorprende que no me hayan
expulsado antes por el tema de los
pendientes si la luz se torna verde
significa que han expulsado al topo y
ganaron si se torna roja significa que
el policía encubierto sigue en la caja y
pierden
lo hicimos esta fatigados podría el
policía encubierto dar un paso adelante
y revelarse en 3 2 1
muy astutos
definitivamente me sorprendió era la
única y quien confiaba sobre todo por la
similitud del crimen es siendo policía
durante dos años me encanta mi trabajo
puedo ayudar a muchas personas por
desgracia cuando me llama los veo en sus
peores días quiero ayudar a las personas
pero no todos aceptan esa ayuda no
puedes juzgar un libro por su portada
pero si los hubiera visto trabajar nunca
habría pensado que alguno hubiera sido
arrestado en algún momento cualquiera es
capaz de cometer un delito pero hay que
aprender de esas cosas y hay que
intentar ser mejor persona después de
haber cometido esos errores tuve que
sentarme y mirarme a mí mismo y adonde
no quería estar en la vida para poder
cambiarlo todo una vez que tienes
antecedentes o una vez que has estado en
la cárcel es casi como si eres un
tramposo siempre lo serás eso no es así
jubilee vive intensamente